a Christmas eye patch and an attic full
of Easter eggs come and rub these hidden
details in A Christmas Story Christmas
we triple dog dare you in A Christmas
Story Ralphie thinks a way to get his
parents to Grant His Wish of getting a
Daisy Red Rider BB gun is by writing an
A plus essay about why it's the perfect
gift why things says writing is strong
Ralphie also knows a bribe won't hurt so
while other kids get their teacher an
apple he gets her a fruit basket in the
new movie A Christmas Story Christmas
Ralphie is a struggling novelist in his
meeting with the publisher he gives the
publisher some candy that he admits is a
bribe in his internal monologue that was
a case back then the bribe doesn't work
and the bribe just goes in a drawer in A
Christmas Story Ralphie has a lot of
dreams about the future in one of his
dreams his paper is such a success that
his teacher Raves about it and his
classmates loved him on their shoulders
as a Great Hero in another fantasy
Ralphie sees a future where he goes
blind because his mom punishes him by
forcing him to put soap in his mouth in
A Christmas Story Christmas Ralph sees a
future where he wins a major literary
award to the Chagrin of the publisher
who rejected him he also sees a future
where his Christmas Eve arrest turns his
daughter into a Teen Mom and his son
into a member of The Sex Pistols then
there's the black bark dream in the
original movie Young Ralphie saves
everybody with his BB gun and Blackboard
threatens to come back in the new movie
Ralph takes on a Clint Eastwood Vibe
this time around however Ralph can't
save his family and ultimately Falls in
battle as an optimistic child he's a
hero as a struggling grown-up he fails
in A Christmas Story Ralphie describes
his father as so some men are Baptists
others Catholics my father was an
Oldsmobile man in A Christmas Story
Christmas Ralph drives an old Plymouth
even more his car is pretty beats up
while his dad had seen himself as a
member of the pit crew in the Indy 500
while there are some similarities the
differences seem to be more prevalent
there's a scene where Ralph goes to buy
a tree attempting to emulate his dad's
ability to negotiate the best price
instead of getting a great deal he
accidentally buys the monster tree that
a lot couldn't sell even more while his
dad is a model of 1940s middle class
success Ralph is a struggling writer
whose wife is supporting the family
though that's actually a sign of
progress from the world of Housewives
and working men the original movie
inhabits one thing stays the same though
Ralph is a devoted to his kids as his
dad was
in A Christmas Story Christmas Ralph has
a Daydream remembering all the perfect
Christmases his dad presided over
they're basically a series of images of
the family presented in Norman
rockwell-esque illustrations most are
actually just Recreations of Rockwell
Classics the Montage is fleeting but
important as it brings to mind the idea
of living up to the old American
Christmas dream it also hearkens to the
look of the original poster the poster
for a Christmas story was illustrated by
Robert Tannenbaum yet look like one of
Norman Rockwell's classic depictions of
Americana the 2012 sequel A Christmas
Story 2 also had a rockwellian poster it
is appropriate that a movie set during
the Heyday of the greatest Generation
adopted a Norman Rockwell ascetic and
its promotions even more it's fitting
that Ralph's daunting attempt to
encapsulate and recreate these moments
was referenced through these classic
illustrations
once you're a parent people are
considerably less interested in what you
want for Christmas maybe that's because
what you wanted to get older is often
less fun than the hottest new toy in A
Christmas Story Ralphie's dad says he
wants a new furnace for Christmas
several times we see his dad head to the
basement to fight their furnace with a
string of expletives and the sound of
clanging echoing throughout the house in
A Christmas Story Christmas Ralph starts
off by asking for his dream gift a time
machine to go back to the beginning of
the year when he and his wife had agreed
he could have a year to pursue his
writing career full time then he
mentions the more realistic gift a new
radiator for his car we see his car's
constant radiator issues which he fixes
with an egg so maybe Ralph and his dad
are more alike than they thought seeing
as they both come to understand that the
Practical things in life sometimes take
precedence to less grounded hopes and
dreams uh Merry Christmas
in A Christmas Story Christmas Ralph
returns to his childhood home for a
Christmas unlike any other seeing as it
will be his first Christmas without his
dad the home looks the same sure but
it's in the Attic where we find the real
Treasures Ralph goes up to the attic
looking for the Christmas ornaments but
is thrown back into his old childhood
while digging through his parents junk
there are tons of nods to the first
movie up there he opens one box and
finds a pink bunny costume a gift from
his Aunt Clara he looks like a deranged
Easter Bunny and he casually tosses
aside the shade to his father's bizarre
leg lamp as a strain of sultry Lounge
music plays for a brief second he also
gets infuriated when he finds a plastic
Christmas tree his mother had bought
then decides the first thing to do is to
go get a real Christmas tree there is
some irony in the fact that his father
instead he was thinking of maybe buying
a plastic tree of course his dad only
said this as a negotiating tactic to get
the Christmas tree salesman to throw in
a piece of rope and tie the tree onto
the family's Oldsmobile
oh man is a fictitious Midwestern City a
Mill Town it would seem set up to
represent any town at USA a central part
of homin is of course a great department
store downtown known as higbee's in A
Christmas Story Ralphie describes
reveling at the higbee's window and in A
Christmas Story Christmas he's still
just as impressed when they go into
higbee's the elves have the same costume
are set up as a slide down from Santa to
the point that Ralph wants his children
about getting a boot in the face
and Santa is still a distraction for the
kids while their parents sharp there's
even a creepy kid in front of the
children in line who pukes when it's
finally his turn to talk to Santa there
are differences though mom and grandma
sit in the lounge drinking while Dad
does all the shopping Julie is a shrewd
negotiator with Santa unlike her father
and this time around we get to see the
Mad Dash of pre-internet gift shopping
that today is relegated to Gen X and
older nostalgia
there are a few more memorable lines
from any Christmas movie than
A Christmas Story Ralphie's mom says it
his teacher says it even Santa says it
to him this simple but famous line was
what everyone told him about why he
shouldn't get a BB gun and sure enough
the first time he shoots the rifle a BB
ricochets into his glasses since his
glasses saved him though there are no
eye injuries in his family that is until
he pegs his daughter with a snowball in
A Christmas Story Christmas in A
Christmas Story Christmas a scene that
most cements Ralph's role is a good dad
is not the gift hunting or the desire to
make them stronger or deliver the
perfect Christmas we see him launch into
an unabashedly joyous snowball fight
with his kids as his car cools down and
we instantly realize how much he loves
his family all is going well until Ralph
turns to launch a distant snowball at
his son Mark and inadvertently hits his
daughter Julie in the eye at point-blank
range as a result sir Julie ends up with
an eye patch
the inclusion of a grown flick and
Schwartz and A Christmas Story Christmas
was a highlight for anybody who grew up
with the movie and wondered whatever
happened to their own childhood friends
of course in the original film you'd
maybe only know them as Ralphie's friend
who stuck his tongue to a pole flick and
the one who tripled dog dared him
Schwartz these days flick owns a bar
where Schwartz as a barfly you can't
help but feel bad for Fleck for the
tongue thing so it's a wonderful moment
to see him get his revenge in A
Christmas Story Christmas in the new
film he tripled dog Dash was to jump
into a snowy field by going down a
frozen slide Schwartz gets his
comeuppance and like all good friends
they follow it with some all his
forgiven camaraderie
it seems like an odd choice to have
Ralphie grow up to be a writer but in A
Christmas Story he does have a scene of
divine inspiration well writing his
essay on why you should get a Daisy Red
Rider BB gun Ralphie describes the words
just flowing out of him into what no
doubt would be a magnificent story in A
Christmas Story Christmas grown-up Ralph
goes to the attic now having failed to
get both his book published and his kids
Christmas presents he describes how the
words pour out of him as he writes about
his father for what was supposed to be
his dad's eulogy in A Christmas Story
the essay doesn't get the grade or
reaction it hopes yes in A Christmas
Story Christmas this flow of inspiration
yields The Story So captivating that it
lands on the front page of the local
paper
there is a timeline tradition of
children running through the
meticulously wrapped gifts they've
received the barkers are no different
what is fun to see though is how similar
Mark and Julie are to Ralph and Randy
when they were kids the chaos at his
Christmas gift opening was captured
perfectly in A Christmas Story and The
Echoes In A Christmas Story Christmas
hits just as hard it starts off
controlled and respectful but then it
quickly explodes into a chaotic scene of
tearing apart wrapping paper even more
in A Christmas Story Ralphie and Randy
both open socks at the same time they
look at their boring gifts then
disinterestedly throw their socks over
their shoulders and get back into
tearing apart wrapping paper in A
Christmas Story Christmas Mark and Julie
get books and throw those over their
shoulders before getting back to work
proving whether we're talking about the
1940s or the 1970s One Thing Remains the
Same kids have no problem running
through their gifts in search of the
ones they actually like
there's a lot to relate to in A
Christmas Story but few parents can deny
that possibly the best scene is when
Ralphie's Mom and Dad get to sit in a
chair together in the dark having
successfully pulled off yet another
Christmas A Christmas Story Christmas
has its own version of the scene but
it's a little different after all
Ralph's dad is gone or is he instead of
Ralph's Mom and Dad basking in the glow
of the tree after all the chaos of the
holiday it's now Ralph and his mom
although this time Ralph and his mom are
worried about the future and missing
Ralph's father then the fuse blows and
of course it happens right when Ralph
and his mom bring up Ralph's dad because
if anything indicates that old man
Parker spirit is still with them it's a
fuse blowing under a Christmas tree and
right when it seemed the only thing
missing was the old man he was here just
like always
[Music]